neuf jours après le drame qui a vu jacob
black devenir paralysé à vie après avoir
été touché dans le dos par cette balle
tirée par un policier
donald trump doit se rendre ce mardi à
kenosha théâtre de l'arrestation
violente depuis ce tragique événement
les manifestations se multiplient dans
tout le pays
une personne a ainsi été tué à portland
ce week-end lors de heurts entre
manifestants anti raciste et partisan de
donald trump pour ne pas attiser les
tensions
le maire de kenosha émis le voeu que le
président américain reporte sa visite
nous avons toujours de la place pour que
les présidents viennent nous rendre
visite et que les candidats viennent
nous rendre visite
c'est le processus habituel et c'est
quelque chose que nous apprécierons mais
nous avons le sentiment que le moment
choisi n'est pas le bon et nous lui
avons donc demandé de faire cette visite
à un autre moment
je pense qu'en ce moment qui nos chats a
besoin de paix besoin de guérir et
besoin que l'on nous laisse faire
cris ponctuent cette demande a été
rejetée par le locataire de la maison
blanche qui a annoncé rendre visite aux
responsables de la police locale
lors de sa dernière conférence de presse
donald trump a ajouté qu'il n'a pas
prévu de rencontrer la famille de jacob
black ce mardi j'ai parlé au pasteur un
homme merveilleux
le pasteur de la famille et j'ai pensé
que ce serait mieux de ne rien faire qui
implique des avocats il voulait que je
parle mais il voulait que des avocats
soit impliqué et j'ai pensé que ce ne
serait pas adéquat
donc je ne l'ait pas fait à neuf
semaines de l'élection présidentielle
joe biden a de son côté accusé donald
trump d'être responsables des violences
qui agitent le pays
le président a depuis longtemps
abandonné toutes qualités morales comme
dirigeant de ce pays
il ne peut pas arrêter la violence car
pendant des années la entretenu vous
savez ils pensent peut-être que
déblatérer les mots loi et ordre
ça le rend fort mais son incapacité à
appeler ses propres partisans à arrêter
de se comporter comme une milice armée à
travers le pays vous montre à quel point
il est faible
la visite de donald trump pourrait donc
être mouvementé
l'émotion est encore dans tous les
esprits ce déplacement du chef d'état
américain pourrait bien jeter de l'huile
sur le feu